this is a production of Cornell
University hello my name is keny
Rodriguez I am a PhD student at Cornell
and I am with Steve reiners a
horiculture professor and Statewide
vegetabl specialist today we'll talk
about pollination so Steve we've um
talked about pollination and watermelon
and what that can do to that but are
there other effects of like pollination
in other curbit crops and how that
affect the fruit of the plant sure so
this is a great example this is cucumber
and you can see in this hand I've got a
cucumber very normally shaped this is
what you'd want um could grow maybe a
couple more days before we typically
Harvest it but it would be fine right
now and then you look at this one this
is from the same plant um and this one
is very crooked as compared to that and
the reason why is that is a pollination
issue um some bees did get over move
some pollen from the male flour to the
female flour and it was probably enough
to just get the fruit set and for it to
start to grow grow but we didn't have
nice uniformity with that with the
pollen in there so there's parts of it
that that weren't sort of fertilized so
that's what's leading to so if we cut
this open later on when the seeds
develop what we'd see is in the normal
Parts the seeds would be normal and
large and in here there probably
wouldn't be any seeds now for a home
Gardener these are fine to eat uh not a
problem at all taste would would be just
like a cucumber but if you're a
commercial grower you'd have a really
hard time trying to grow that and this
pollination issue that we see another
very common question we get from from
gardeners is they often will they've
read somewhere that again with the the
bees out in a curbing field they can
move the pollen from from one plant to
another what happens when they move that
pollen from a a cucumber to a melon or
from a melon to a squash well that cross
and then they might see something in
their Garden this year that looks odd
and they think it was because of the
Cross but let's talk about that um first
off
if in curbit
within pumpkins and squash uh winter
squash there can be some
cross-pollination that can occur but
it's impossible I'll repeat that again
it's impossible for a cucumber to cross
with a melon or a melon to cross with a
squash or for a pumpkin to to to to
cross with a watermelon it just cannot
happen in nature at all so
usually when you do see maybe a zucchini
that crosses with a pumpkin you won't
see that
change that year it will only be if you
save the seeds and where this can happen
sometimes is People are cleaning out
their Gardens in the in the fall and
they'll throw their old rotting squash
and things like that in the compost pile
and then they get a volunteer plant the
following year and it flowers and it
produces a fruit that looks a little bit
like a squash or pumpkin might look a
little bit like a zucchini sometimes we
call them sampkin sort the combination
but again it was from the seed it won't
it will not happen you will not see the
effects of that cross that first year
when it happens because what you're
seeing here what the what the outside of
this is all maternal tissue so it should
be whatever you planted um the seeds is
where the genetics have changed so if
you see that and something you've
planted this year and you say yeah but I
I planted the seed and I know it was a a
cucumber and it's come out weird it's
possible that there was a little mixup
at the seed company or maybe a mixup
when you were planting it themselves and
you put the wrong seed in but again you
won't see that unless you hold on to
those seeds for a year and plant them
out the following year Stephen just to
conclude so even if I see bees in my
field that doesn't mean that all the
flowers are going to get like pollinated
completely pollinated to get a good food
right uh yeah it actually takes I think
they've done some work in watermelons
where they think it might take anywhere
from 10 to 15 B visits um to move enough
pollen over to that flow so so even
though you think well there's bees there
you might even bring bees out a lot of
Growers will bring bees out into their
fields but they might go to other places
where they prefer the pollen source so
yeah so just because you see the bees
you want to see the bees but there's no
guarantee that they're as active as they
should in your curbit field yeah that's
very important to know so we just
learned about pollination how the food
can be me me shapen and also some
advices on like um how to uh check when
you have a cross but you know that you
will you won't have it in the first
season if you have your crop in um the
field this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu